When I first heard about the new Chinese national security law that went into effect this month in Hong Kong, the person I wanted to talk to about it is this Hong Kong protester that I will call Jennifer. Jennifer is somebody who I and a couple of other producers from our show spent time with and went to protest with last fall.
当我第一次听说本月在香港生效的中国新国家安全法时，我最想聊的人是一位香港抗议者，我暂且称她为詹妮弗。詹妮弗是我和我们节目的几位制作人去年秋天花时间陪伴并一起参加抗议活动的人。
So many things that she said to us back then would now be illegal under the new Chinese law. In fact, any criticism of China or the Hong Kong government, anybody calling for democracy in Hong Kong anywhere in the world, could be prosecuted under this law.
当时她对我们说的许多话，在现在的中国新法律下都是非法的。事实上，任何对中国或香港政府的批评，任何在世界任何地方呼吁香港民主的行为，都可能依据该法律受到起诉。
Calling for the United States to support the protesters, which Jennifer did, that is illegal. If the Chinese decide that talking to reporters like us is collusion with foreigners, that would be illegal. Chanting at protests about Hong Kong independence has been declared illegal. Damaging subway stations is categorized as terrorism with severe penalties.
呼吁美国支持抗议者，詹妮弗曾这样做过，这是非法的。如果中国认定与我们这样的记者交谈就是勾结外国势力，那也是非法的。在抗议活动中高呼香港独立已被宣布为非法。破坏地铁站被归类为恐怖主义，并会受到严厉惩罚。
Books by activists have been removed from public libraries. People have been arrested for carrying pro-independence flags. China is setting up its own separate national security apparatus in Hong Kong to handle these cases. Maximum penalty-- life in prison.
活动人士的书籍已从公共图书馆下架。人们因携带支持独立的旗帜而被捕。中国正在香港建立自己独立的国家安全机构来处理这些案件。最高刑罚是终身监禁。
What we're going to do today on our program is play you the episode that we made last fall about the Hong Kong protesters, where we tried to explain the feelings and the ideals behind the protests. And then, at the end of the hour, we will play you the interview that I just did with Jennifer this month on the second full day that the new law went into effect about the law.
今天我们的节目将播放我们去年秋天制作的关于香港抗议者的那一集，我们试图解释抗议背后的感受和理想。然后在节目结束时，我们将播放我本月在新法生效后的第二天刚刚对詹妮弗进行的采访，谈论这部法律。
If you're listening to the podcast version of our show and you heard this episode when we first put it out in the fall and you just want to jump to the new part with Jennifer, the new interview, it starts around 14 minutes from the end. OK, here's the episode.
如果你正在收听我们的播客版本，并且在秋天我们首播时听过这一集，而你只想直接跳转到关于詹妮弗的新部分，也就是新的采访，它大约在结束前14分钟开始。好了，这就是那一集。
It's nearly 2:00 in the afternoon when we reach Jennifer's family's apartment. She's just gotten up. She's still eating a very late breakfast.
当我们到达詹妮弗家所在的公寓时，已经是下午两点多了。她刚起床。她还在吃一份非常晚的早餐。
I'll finish my noodles, then I'll start packing.
我吃完面条就开始打包。
I'm with my co-worker, Emanuele Berry, and we're in a quiet working class neighborhood in the part of Hong Kong that's called New Territories. It's a Sunday, so Jennifer is getting ready to do what she does every weekend-- what she did yesterday, in fact. That's why she slept late. She's going to a protest-- with a little backpack.
我和我的同事伊曼纽尔·贝里在一起，我们位于香港一个安静的工人阶级社区，被称为新界。今天是周日，所以詹妮弗正准备做她每个周末都做的事情——事实上她昨天也做了。这就是她睡懒觉的原因。她要去参加抗议活动——背着一个小背包。
So this is the bag that I usually bring.
这就是我通常带的包。
So this is a maroon bag.
这是一个褐红色的包。
It's a very small one. We have to keep everything light. So I always have a bottle of water and many tissues. I have to bring a lot of tissues, because we need to wipe our eyes when there is tear gas. And because I know how to do first aid, I always bring my first aid kit.
它非常小。我们必须保持轻便。所以我总是带一瓶水和很多纸巾。我必须带很多纸巾，因为当有催泪瓦斯时我们需要擦眼睛。而且因为我知道怎么进行急救，我总是随身携带急救包。
The first aid kit is a little zip-up bag with roller bandages and gauze and gloves and stuff to sterilize a wound. Jennifer started at the volunteer ambulance corps in seventh grade and has used all this stuff at demonstrations. She packs her wallet and her AirPods.
急救包是一个带拉链的小袋子，里面有卷轴绷带、纱布、手套和消毒伤口的东西。詹妮弗从七年级开始就在志愿救护队工作，并曾在示威活动中使用过所有这些装备。她装上了钱包和耳机。
Because I have to listen to songs.
因为我必须听歌。
Two batteries for her phone, because she's on it constantly during protests, checking the continuously-updated online maps that show where the police are and show escape routes. She packs a black T-shirt. The uniform of the Hong Kong protesters is black shirt, black pants, surgical masks to disguise their identities-- though she's wearing a striped maroon shirt for the bus ride to the protest.
还有两块手机电池，因为她在抗议期间不停地使用手机，查看实时更新的在线地图，了解警察的位置和逃生路线。她装了一件黑色T恤。香港抗议者的制服是黑衬衫、黑裤子、医用口罩，用来隐藏身份——尽管她在去抗议的巴士上穿着一件条纹褐红色衬衫。
Yeah, I wear a normal T-shirt when I go out so that no one can identify I am going to a protest. And sometimes I bring makeup so that I can transform myself after the protest.
是的，我出门时穿普通的T恤，这样没人能认出我是去参加抗议的。有时我会带化妆品，这样抗议结束后我可以变换一下形象。
I don't understand. How do you transform yourself? Like, what's the--
我不明白。你如何变换形象？比如，什么是……
I bring foundation-- very small, but can do everything.
我带粉底——非常小，但什么都能做。
How different are you going to look with that foundation?
用那粉底你会看起来有多大不同？
No, it looks like you're not going to protest. Because girls who are going to protest, they barely do makeup. But if girl is doing makeup, they're probably meeting someone. And so I bring this one. And then of course, I bring my brow pencil. Because it really can make you look like another person.
不，看起来就像你不是去抗议。因为去抗议的女生几乎不化妆。但如果女生在化妆，她们可能是在见什么人。所以我带了这个。当然，我还带了眉笔。因为那真的能让你看起来像另外一个人。
Eyebrows are very important, I agree.
眉毛非常重要，我同意。
Yeah. [LAUGHS] And I bring lipstick. I'm sorry, it's a very small room.
是的。[笑]我还带了口红。抱歉，这是一个非常小的房间。
So we're in your room. Your room has pink walls. And there is a bunk bed with the bed on the top and a desk underneath it.
我们在你的房间里。你的房间有粉红色的墙壁。有一个双层床，上面是床，下面是书桌。
Yeah, it's very typical Hong Kong girl's room.
是的，这是非常典型的香港女孩的房间。
For a Hong Kong protester to live at home with her mom and dad, that is not unusual in any way. If you know anything about the demonstrations that have overtaken Hong Kong since June, you know it's mostly young people in the city where rents are high. Jennifer is 22 and just graduated college. She's working her first entry-level job at a public relations firm.
对于一名香港抗议者来说，和父母住在一起并不罕见。如果你了解自六月以来席卷香港的示威活动，你就会知道，在租金高昂的城市里，参与者大多是年轻人。詹妮弗22岁，刚大学毕业。她正在一家公关公司做第一份入门级工作。
I came to Hong Kong because there were things about the protests that I really did not understand. And we'll get to that. One of things that fascinated me once I arrived was learning what a routine the protests have become and what that was like for the people in them. This was mid-September, the 13th week of protests for Jennifer.
我来香港是因为抗议活动中有些事情我真的不理解。我们稍后会谈到这一点。我到达后感到着迷的事情之一，是了解到抗议活动已经变得多么常规化，以及这对参与其中的人来说是什么样子的。那是九月中旬，对詹妮弗来说是抗议的第13周。
I'm not really worried because it's just like another day. I think I will meet up with two friends of mine. But I'm not sure if I am going to because they are couple, so I don't want to be-- [LAUGHS] they are couple, so I don't want to be-- they always kiss next to me. So, mm, yeah.
我不怎么担心，因为这就像普通的一天。我想我会和两个朋友见面。但我不确定是否会去，因为他们是情侣，所以我不想……[笑]他们是情侣，所以我不想……他们总是在我旁边接吻。所以，嗯，是的。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[用中文说话]
Speak of the devil, it's her friend, the one who kisses her boyfriend at demonstrations. And she's calling with bad news. She was going to bring gas masks to the rally today. They'd order them from Amazon, Jennifer thinks. But now she's learned that bringing gas masks would be a bad idea, because at the subway station--
说曹操曹操就到，是她的朋友，那个在示威中和男友接吻的人。她打来电话带来了坏消息。她本来打算今天带防毒面具去集会。詹妮弗认为他们是从亚马逊订购的。但现在她得知带防毒面具不是个好主意，因为在地铁站……
Police are searching everybody, including men, little ones, and young people like us. They're searching their bags. And if they have any equipment with them like the gas mask, eye mask, whatever, they just arrest them. Yeah. So my friend just asked me if it is a must for me to get the gas mask. So I told her that no, it is not a must. I don't want to risk my friend getting searched. So she told the other friend not to come out with equipment.
警察正在搜查每一个人，包括男人、小孩和像我们这样的年轻人。他们搜查他们的包。如果他们携带任何装备，比如防毒面具、眼罩之类的，他们就会直接逮捕。所以我的朋友刚才问我带防毒面具是不是必须的。我告诉她，不，这不是必须的。我不想冒着让朋友被搜查的风险。所以她告诉另一个朋友不要带装备出来。
Not ideal, but she's gone without gas masks before. Jennifer grabs her knapsack, says bye to her mom, who tells her to come home early, a request that will be totally ignored. And we head outside. But then she turns and runs back.
虽然不太理想，但她以前也曾不带防毒面具去过。詹妮弗抓起背包，跟妈妈告别，妈妈让她早点回家，这个要求完全被忽略了。我们走到外面。但接着她转身跑了回去。
What did you forget?
你忘了什么？
Uh, umbrella. It is very important to have umbrella.
呃，雨伞。带雨伞非常重要。
Even if it's not going to rain?
即使没打算下雨？
Yeah. It is not for the rain. It is for tear gas and bullets.
是的。这不是为了挡雨。这是为了抵挡催泪瓦斯和子弹。
Rubber bullets, that is.
是橡胶子弹。
It works on bullets?
它对子弹有效吗？
Yes. Frankly, yes. No, no, I don't understand why, but always, those bullets, they slip off along the umbrella. edge. So they just-- they don't get through the umbrella.
是的。坦白说，是的。不，不，我不明白为什么，但那些子弹总是会顺着伞缘滑掉。所以它们只是……它们没法穿过雨伞。
Also, protesters hide behind a wall of umbrellas when they're painting graffiti or dismantling a closed circuit TV camera on the street, doing anything else they don't want the police to see. As she and I and Emanuele head to the bus stop, we notice other young people carrying full-sized umbrellas on this totally sunny day.
此外，当他们在街上喷涂涂鸦或拆除闭路电视摄像头，或做任何不想让警察看到的事情时，抗议者会躲在雨伞墙后面。当我和伊曼纽尔陪她走向巴士站时，我们注意到其他年轻人在这个阳光明媚的日子里也拿着全尺寸的雨伞。
Walking over here to the bus, are you looking around to see if-- other people you think are going to protest?
走到这里乘巴士，你会环顾四周看是否……有其他你认为要去参加抗议的人吗？
Yeah, you always want to know how many people are around you, right? Yeah.
是的，你总是想知道周围有多少人，对吧？是的。
OK, and so there's some young people on our left, two people standing next to you.
好的，左边有几个年轻人，你旁边站着两个人。
I think the girl probably is not because she brings a very small bag. But the tall guy, the tall guy in white shirt--
我觉得那个女生可能不是，因为她带的是个很小的包。但那个高个子，穿白衬衫的高个子……
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Yeah, and then the couple behind you, probably.
是的，还有你身后的那对情侣，可能也是。
It's like, are you on my side? Are you one of us? Once you're at the protest, everybody's in a mask so you don't really know who's on your team. Here in the neighborhood, it's kind of exciting to wonder who your allies might be.
这就像是，你是站在我这边的吗？你是我们的一员吗？一旦到了抗议现场，每个人都戴着口罩，所以你真的不知道谁是你的队友。在这里，好奇谁可能是盟友其实挺令人兴奋的。
The protests in Hong Kong have been international news for months, kicked off by people's fears that mainland China is threatening some very basic things about their city and their lives. But for all the coverage here at our show, we felt like we weren't seeing many stories where we got to know anybody very well-- who they were, what exactly they expected was going to come out of the protests, given China's intransigence.
香港的抗议活动几个月来一直是国际新闻，起因是人们担心中国大陆正威胁到他们城市和生活中的一些非常基本的东西。但对于我们节目所做的所有报道，我们觉得我们看到的很多报道并没有让我们深入了解任何一个人——他们是谁，考虑到中国的不妥协，他们到底期望抗议能带来什么。
Three of us arrived in Hong Kong in mid-September, me and Emanuele and a co-worker, Diane Wu. I have to say, one of the things that was fascinating, given the ugly state of democracy here in the United States lately, was to be among so many young people who believe so intensely in democratic ideals and yearn so deeply for the basics, like normal elections and free speech and free assembly.
我们三个人九月中旬到达香港，我和伊曼纽尔，还有一位同事黛安·吴。我不得不说，考虑到美国近期民主的糟糕状态，能身处这么多如此强烈地信仰民主理想，并如此渴望正常选举、言论自由和集会自由等基本权利的年轻人中间，是一件令人着迷的事情。
Though, just in the last few weeks since we got to Hong Kong, we've watched the situation changed dramatically. It's gotten much more violent, harsh new measures by the government.
不过，就在我们到达香港的最后几周里，我们目睹了局势的急剧变化。它变得更加暴力，政府采取了更严厉的新措施。
This hour, we have the story of the change that we witnessed and what we think it might mean. If you haven't been following the story at all-- maybe you've been sitting this one out-- we're going to catch you up on what you need to know. We have all sorts of people from all sides of this that we want you to meet.
这一小时，我们将讲述我们目睹的变化，以及我们认为这意味着什么。如果你根本没有关注这个故事——也许你一直置身事外——我们将带你了解你需要知道的事情。我们想让你见到各方面的各种人。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. This week, overseas with a lot of people who have some very American values. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。本周，在海外与许多持有非常有美国价值观的人在一起。请继续收听。
Act One, The Cursed Generation. OK, so what politicized thousands and thousands of people this much, that they've dropped their normal lives and they're coming out every single weekend to protest? It's now been 18 straight weeks.
第一幕，被诅咒的一代。好了，那么到底是什么让成千上万的人如此政治化，以至于他们放弃了正常生活，每个周末都出来抗议？现在已经是连续18周了。
Take Jennifer, for instance. She's somebody who worked at Abercrombie and Fitch during college. She told me on the bus to the protests that's why her English is so good. She's somebody who wanted to be a singer. Actually got a chance to go pro when she was 16, but her mom quashed that, saying it was too much of a long shot and she should get an education and get a normal job. Jennifer was actually very surprised when I informed her that an American parent might have said the same exact thing.
以詹妮弗为例。她在大学期间曾在Abercrombie and Fitch工作过。她在去抗议的巴士上告诉我，这就是为什么她的英语这么好。她曾经想成为一名歌手。事实上在16岁时有机会走上专业道路，但被她妈妈否定了，说那成功的几率太渺茫，她应该去接受教育，找一份正常的工作。当我告诉她美国父母可能会说完全相同的话时，詹妮弗感到非常惊讶。
Oh, I thought American dreams can be true, something like that, because I watched Glee.
哦，我以为美国梦是可以实现的，类似那样，因为我看过《欢乐合唱团》。
So how did this Glee watching, internet savvy college grad in her first office job, how did she end up protesting in the street every weekend with tens or-- I don't know-- maybe it's hundreds of thousands of her peers? Well, for starters, Jennifer's 22, which means she's part of a special generation in Hong Kong.
那么，这个看《欢乐合唱团》、精通互联网、有着第一份办公室工作的大学毕业生，是如何最终每个周末和成千上万甚至几十万的同龄人一起走上街头抗议的呢？首先，詹妮弗22岁，这意味着她是香港特殊一代的一员。
I'm born in Hong Kong in 1997, right before the handover.
我是1997年在香港出生的，就在移交前夕。
And here's a protester we're calling Alice.
这位是我们称为爱丽丝的抗议者。
And I'm born in 1997.
我也是1997年出生的。
Here's her friend we're calling Tiffany.
这是她的朋友，我们称为蒂芙尼。
I'm also born in 1997.
我也是1997年出生的。
You can call me Yuen, and I'm born in 1997.
你可以叫我Yuen，我也是1997年出生的。
So 1997 is the year when Hong Kong was handed over back to China from the British.
所以1997年是香港从英国交还给中国的年份。
OK, let's just pause on these 22-year-olds for a minute for some quick history. As you may or may not know, Hong Kong sits on the edge of mainland China, right? It was a British colony for a really long time, starting in the 19th century.
好的，让我们先暂停一下这些22岁年轻人的叙述，回顾一下简短的历史。正如你可能知道或不知道的那样，香港位于中国大陆的边缘，对吧？它在19世纪长期是英国的殖民地。
And then finally in 1997, the British got out. They handed it over to China. And the idea was, there was going to be a 50-year transition period. After 50 years, China would fully be in charge. But during that 50 years, Hong Kong would be a democracy.
最终在1997年，英国人撤走了。他们把它交还给了中国。当时的设想是有一个50年的过渡期。50年后，中国将完全掌权。但在那50年里，香港将是一个民主社会。
Now Hong Kong people are to run Hong Kong.
现在由香港人来治理香港。
That's the last British governor of Hong Kong during the handover ceremony in 1997.
那是1997年移交仪式上香港末代总督的话。
That is the promise. And that is the unshakeable destiny.
这是承诺。这是不可动摇的命运。
But to be clear, Hong Kong had not been a democracy under Britain. But they were going to transition towards it over a bunch of years. And the hope was, after 50 years, in 2047, the Chinese government would let them stay a democracy-- which, at the time, did not seem like a crazy idea.
但要明确的是，在英国统治下，香港并不是一个民主社会。但他们将在多年内向民主过渡。当时的希望是，50年后的2047年，中国政府会让他们保持民主——这在当时看来并非疯狂的想法。
China was opening up in all kinds of ways, though it wasn't clear how this was going to play out. And at the end of the day, after 50 years, in the year 2047, China was going to be able to do whatever it wanted in Hong Kong. These are the children born the year that clock started ticking.
中国正在以各种方式开放，尽管还不清楚未来会如何发展。总之，50年后，即2047年，中国将能够在香港做任何它想做的事。这些孩子出生在那钟声开始敲响的一年。
And have you heard of the phrase, "cursed generation"?
你听说过“被诅咒的一代”这个词吗？
Yes, it was a joke among the 1997 people.
是的，这是1997年出生的人当中的一个笑话。
It was pretty much a joke or pretty much a funny thing to us, because--
这对我们来说几乎是一个笑话或一件很有趣的事情，因为……
I think when we first joked about it, it's really primary schools, but--
我想我们刚开始拿它开玩笑时，是在小学，但是……
The cursed generation is just what we've been joking around for all those years.
被诅咒的一代就是我们这些年来一直开玩笑说的。
Originally, the joke had to do with a coincidence. They were cursed because of some weird, bad luck during some big childhood milestones they all went through together, like the year of their kindergarten graduation, the SARS virus hit Hong Kong. And the city shut down, graduations were canceled.
最初，这个笑话与巧合有关。他们被诅咒是因为在他们一起经历的一些重要童年里程碑中遇到了一些奇怪的倒霉事，比如他们幼儿园毕业那年，SARS病毒袭击了香港。城市关闭了，毕业典礼被取消。
Six years later, when they should have had their elementary school graduation, same thing happened again, but with swine flu. And Jennifer remembers that her friends joked that when they graduated high school, it was going to be Ebola. And that's when they started using the word "cursed."
六年之后，当他们应该小学毕业时，同样的事情又发生了，只是变成了猪流感。詹妮弗记得她的朋友们开玩笑说，等他们高中毕业时，就该是埃博拉了。那时他们开始使用“被诅咒”这个词。
I think that was around the time that J.K. Rowling wrote Harry Potter and the Cursed Child. Yeah, so many of us-- oh, we're the cursed child. Or we say that we are the chosen one because Harry Potter was the chosen one. All of us love Harry Potter. So we always think that, oh, we are the chosen one. We have to face something special in our life. Or we are the cursed one. We have to face something bad or face something significant.
我想那大概是J.K.罗琳写《哈利·波特与被诅咒的孩子》的时候。是的，我们很多人……哦，我们是被诅咒的孩子。或者我们说我们是天选之子，因为哈利·波特是天选之子。我们所有人都爱《哈利·波特》。所以我们总是认为，哦，我们是天选之子。我们生活中必须面对一些特殊的事情。或者我们是被诅咒的人。我们必须面对一些坏事或重要的事情。
Jennifer says the "chosen one" side of things didn't really kick in until their senior year of high school. It was 2014. They were 17, the 17th year since the handover. And that year, people in Hong Kong were still expecting that mainland China was going to let them start holding full-on elections, where they could choose their own leaders, as promised back in 1997. And that year, China announced it wasn't going to happen.
詹妮弗说“天选之子”那一面在他们高三之前并没有真正显现。那是2014年。他们17岁，正是移交后的第17个年头。那一年，香港人仍然期待中国大陆会让他们开始举行全面选举，让他们能够像1997年承诺的那样选择自己的领导人。那一年，中国宣布这不会发生。
This led to a movement called the Umbrella Movement, headed by young people, teenagers, who'd learned their politics in these public school classes that all these 22-year-olds talk about as being instrumental in their thinking, classes that began as part of the handover called Liberal Studies classes that explained, among other things, the promises of 1997 and the rights of Hong Kong citizens.
这导致了一场被称为“雨伞运动”的运动，由年轻人和青少年领导。他们在所有这些22岁年轻人提到的公共学校课程中学习政治，这些课程被称为“通识教育”，是移交开始时的一部分，除了其他内容外，还解释了1997年的承诺和香港公民的权利。
They took to the streets, most of them for the first time, demanding to vote, carrying umbrellas, thousands of people in a vast procession down the streets in a protest movement that was almost entirely peaceful. And they lost. They didn't get the vote. After three months, the protests ended.
他们走上街头，大多数人是第一次，要求投票权，撑着雨伞，成千上万的人在街头进行大规模的游行，这是一场几乎完全和平的抗议运动。但他们失败了。他们没有得到投票权。三个月后，抗议结束了。
Alice works for a multinational company in an entry level job out of college. She's a management trainee. She says she went to some protests back then out of solidarity with her peers.
爱丽丝大学毕业后在一家跨国公司从事入门级工作。她是管理培训生。她说当时她去参加了一些抗议活动，是为了支持她的同龄人。
I was just amazed by the other students.
我对其他学生感到惊讶。
But she didn't really get all the politics. That changed in June 2019, when Hong Kong introduced the bill that would allow mainland China to extradite people from Hong Kong to be tried and punished in China under Chinese law.
但她并没有真正理解所有的政治。2019年6月，情况发生了变化，当时香港引入了一项法案，允许中国大陆将香港人引渡到中国，根据中国法律进行审判和惩罚。
This was seen as a new and very menacing encroachment on the rights of Hong Kong citizens. Since 1997, they'd been ruled by Hong Kong laws and Hong Kong courts. Everybody is presumed innocent with the rights we know in most democratic countries. Now anybody could get thrown into the prisons and courts of communist China.
这被视为对香港公民权利的一种新的且非常有威胁的侵犯。自1997年以来，他们一直受香港法律和香港法院管辖。每个人都被推定无罪，享有我们在大多数民主国家所知的权利。现在任何人都有可能被扔进共产中国的监狱和法院。
I would say that was the time when I first feel awakened, when I'm truly understanding what's happening when I first go to the march of the no extradition bill. And I was very, very emotional at that time, because there is only around 7 million people in Hong Kong, but 1 million walk on the street with the same demand, with the same wish of having Hong Kong to remain its current state.
我会说那是让我第一次感到觉醒的时候，当我第一次去参加反引渡法案游行时，我真正理解了正在发生的事情。当时我非常、非常激动，因为香港只有大约700万人，但有100万人走上街头，带着同样的诉求，带着希望香港保持现状的愿望。
Wanting Hong Kong to stay like it is, with its own laws, separate from China. A week later, 2 million people came out.
希望香港保持现状，拥有自己的法律，与中国分离。一周后，200万人走出来。
At the time, I was feeling very, oh my God, this is so touching. Why is people so united? And then the next second, the government just declares that, oh, we heard your voice, but we will be continuing on the bill on Tuesday. So that was a really big contrast.
当时，我感到，天哪，这太感人了。为什么人们如此团结？然后下一秒，政府就宣布，哦，我们听到了你们的声音，但我们周二将继续推进该法案。这真是一个巨大的反差。
And in the morning, you see how peaceful things were. But at night, you see the police coming out and start brutally hitting people. It was really unforgettable to me because that was the first time when I witnessed with my real eyes that the police is chasing people. They are chasing students who did not do anything and start to beat them and arrest them.
早上，你看到事情是多么和平。但到了晚上，你看到警察出来，开始残酷地殴打人们。这对我来说真的很令人难忘，因为那是我第一次亲眼目睹警察在追逐人们。他们追逐那些什么都没做的学生，并开始殴打和逮捕他们。
Other 22-year-olds also told us how radicalizing it's been to see police tear gassing and beating peaceful protesters. And at this point-- I didn't understand this before we got to Hong Kong-- a lot of the emotion driving the protests is just about the police.
其他22岁的年轻人也告诉我们，看到警察使用催泪瓦斯和殴打和平抗议者是多么激进。此时此刻——在去香港之前我不明白这一点——驱动抗议活动的许多情绪仅仅是针对警察的。
Because the government is supporting them to do such things. And there is no penalty for them, even if they are doing things that are completely unacceptable to everyone.
因为政府支持他们做这样的事情。而且他们没有任何惩罚，即使他们做的事情对每个人来说都是完全不可接受的。
Of course, nobody knows where this is going to lead by 2047, when China fully takes over Hong Kong. But for Jennifer and lots of other people her age, things are starting to feel pretty ominous. Was Hong Kong going to become just like any other Chinese city run by the communists?
当然，没人知道到2047年中国完全接管香港时，这一切会走向何方。但对于詹妮弗和她这个年纪的许多其他人来说，事情开始变得相当不祥。香港会变得像中国任何一个由共产党治理的城市一样吗？
When you're 50, what do you picture life here will be like?
当你50岁时，你想象那里的生活会是什么样？
I can picture that I will be super depressed because I super comment on political things. I really cannot imagine that day that I cannot speak freely on internet, that we do not have that freedom of speech anymore. And I cannot imagine that there will come a day me and my friends commenting on the government would become a crime.
我能想象我会变得超级抑郁，因为我对政治事物发表评论。我真的无法想象有一天我不能在互联网上自由发言，我们不再拥有那样的言论自由。我无法想象有一天我和我的朋友对政府发表评论会成为犯罪。
And you think that would happen.
你认为那会发生。
Yes, I do, when all the things that is happening in mainland China now, especially, I would say, in-- where is it-- Xinjiang.
是的，我认为会，尤其是当现在中国大陆正在发生的一切，我会说，在……它在哪里……新疆。
Xinjiang, mm-hmm.
新疆，嗯。
Yeah, what is happening in Xinjiang will happen in Hong Kong.
是的，发生在新疆的事会发生在香港。
She's talking about internment camps, where the Chinese are holding perhaps a million Uighurs and others.
她说的是拘留营，中国在那里关押了或许一百万维吾尔族人和其他人。
They say it's reeducation, but it's basically a concentration camp. They put people who do not agree with the government into the concentration camp and educate them. And they got monitored wherever and whenever they go. Everywhere is police. Police monitors everybody's move. And I do think that if we do not fight for our future, there will come a day Hong Kong would become like Xinjiang.
他们说是再教育，但基本上就是集中营。他们把不同意政府的人关进集中营并教育他们。无论何时何地他们都被监控。到处都是警察。警察监控每一个人的行动。而且我真的认为，如果我们不为我们的未来而战，香港会有变成新疆的那一天。
Because she's politically active, this does not feel like an abstract threat. When these 22-year-olds picture who China's going to crack down on, it's them. Tiffany's also in her first job out of college. She works at a bank. She asked us to replace her voice with an actor's.
因为她热衷于政治，这感觉不像是一个抽象的威胁。当这些22岁的年轻人设想中国会镇压谁时，那就是他们。蒂芙尼也在大学毕业后的第一份工作中。她在银行工作。她要求我们用演员的声音替换她的声音。
Who knows whatever they would do to us? And the extradition bill, who knows where we will go, what time we will disappear? That's what we fear of.
谁知道他们会对我们做什么？还有引渡法案，谁知道我们会去哪里，什么时候会消失？这就是我们所恐惧的。
Tiffany's heard of the social credit system that China has started to monitor and rate its citizens. She fears that if China decides that you're anti-government, it will make it impossible for you to get the job you want or rise in society.
蒂芙尼听说过中国用来监控和评级其公民的社会信用体系。她担心如果中国认定你是反政府的，就会让你无法获得想要的工作或在社会中晋升。
And the devices that China uses to monitor its population, an estimated 200 million surveillance cameras around the country with facial recognition software, they've been going up around Hong Kong, tens of thousands of them.
而中国用来监控其人口的设备，全国估计有2亿个带有面部识别软件的监控摄像头，它们已经在香港各地出现，成千上万个。
Many, like me, are scared of being monitored and rated so that we will never, ever be free to do anything that we want under the monitoring of the Chinese government.
许多像我这样的人，害怕被监控和评分，以至于我们在中国政府的监控下，永远、永远无法自由地做任何我们想做的事情。
This is something else I didn't understand before I came to Hong Kong. The protesters like Tiffany and Jennifer don't just fear what's going to happen to them in the future with extradition laws or losing the internet or losing free speech.
这是我在来香港之前不理解的另一件事。像蒂芙尼和詹妮弗这样的抗议者不仅害怕未来引渡法或失去互联网或言论自由对她们会发生什么。
In their daily lives right now, they believe they're watching China already transforming Hong Kong, making it less like the Hong Kong they know and more like the mainland. Jennifer points to changes in the public school curricula, like, she says, her seven-year-old nephew is speaking Mandarin in school five days a week. It didn't happen when she was a kid. Mandarin is what they speak in mainland China. In Hong Kong, people mostly speak in Cantonese and in English.
在她们现在的日常生活中，她们认为她们正在目睹中国已经在改造香港，使其变得不像她们所认识的香港，而更像中国大陆。詹妮弗指出了公立学校课程的变化，她说，她七岁的侄子每周五天在学校说普通话。她小时候没发生过这种事。普通话是中国大陆说的语言。在香港，人们主要说广东话和英语。
So all the Chinese classes are conducted in Mandarin. So he speaks Mandarin everyday, basically. He speaks Mandarin better than English.
所以所有的中文课都是用普通话进行的。所以他基本上每天都在说普通话。他说普通话比说英语还好。
Can you explain a little bit why Cantonese is so important?
你能解释一下为什么广东话这么重要吗？
Cantonese is more like an identity to us.
广东话更像是我们的一种身份。
It's part of what makes Hong Kong, Hong Kong. These days, when Jennifer pictures what her life is going to be like between now and 2047, she imagines her own kids going to public schools, not studying Cantonese, coming home and parroting the pro-government line that'll be the curriculum by then.
这是使香港成为香港的一部分。这些天，当詹妮弗设想从现在到2047年她的生活会是什么样时，她想象自己的孩子去公立学校，不学习广东话，回家背诵到那时已成为课程内容的亲政府路线。
So I do love kids. I really want to have kids. I want to have a football team of kids, really. But I just cannot imagine the life they will be having in Hong Kong later on. I cannot promise my kid a happy life if I am not certain about what will Hong Kong become.
所以我确实喜欢孩子。我真的想有孩子。我真的很想有一个足球队那么多的孩子。但我只是无法想象他们以后在香港会过什么样的生活。如果我不确定香港会变成什么样，我就不能给我的孩子承诺幸福的生活。
You don't think there are children who are raised to be happy in mainland China?
你不认为中国大陆也有被抚养得很幸福的孩子吗？
Not the kind of happy that I think. Mainland China people, they think that they are happy because they can still live. But then we want things more than just surviving in this society. We look for rights and freedoms and human rights. But the mainland Chinese, they ignore all those things. They just think, having a stable life, having kids, having food, a good place to live in, is already happy enough. Yeah.
不是我认为的那种幸福。中国大陆的人，他们认为他们很幸福，因为他们还能活下去。但我们想要的不仅仅是在这个社会里生存。我们寻求权利、自由和人权。但中国大陆人，他们忽视了所有这些事情。他们只是认为，有一个稳定的生活，有孩子，有食物，有一个好的居住地方，就已经足够幸福了。是的。
Another change she says she's seeing right now in Hong Kong, she's upset at other mainlanders moving there in her neighborhood, and university students that she and her friends encountered at college. So many mainlanders, she says.
她说她现在在香港看到的另一个变化，她对搬到她社区的其他大陆人，以及她和朋友在大学遇到的大学生感到不满。她说，太多大陆人了。
I just feel really weird because I am born and raised in Hong Kong. I go to a local school, but then I have to be surrounded by all the mainlanders.
我只是觉得真的很奇怪，因为我是土生土长的香港人。我上本地学校，但我却必须被所有的大陆人包围。
Does it bother you to be surrounded by mainlanders?
被大陆人包围会困扰你吗？
Yes, actually, quite. But then we have 150 new immigrants from China to Hong Kong every day.
是的，其实，很困扰。但我们每天有150名新移民从中国来到香港。
OK, I'm just going to pause the tape right there for a second. The total, by the way, is over a million mainlanders since 1997, roughly 45,000 a year. But I'm stopping the tape because I don't know how you're feeling about Jennifer, but this was a point we came to in a few interviews with these 22-year-olds. When you got them under the subject of mainlanders, get ready for a wave of totally bigoted opinions.
好的，我先暂停一下磁带。顺便说一下，自1997年以来总数超过一百万大陆人，大约每年4.5万人。但我停止录音是因为，我不知道你对詹妮弗是什么感觉，但这是我们在与这些22岁年轻人进行几次采访时遇到的一个点。当你触及大陆人这个话题时，准备好迎接一波完全偏执的观点吧。
So, especially I live in New Territories. So all the people surrounding you, you hear Mandarin. And then you start to see those less-educated people. They're squatting next to the streets. I did witness a mainland lady having her children pee at the road. And I always hear mainland people yelling, shouting out for nothing in the mall. And always, they jump into the line. Everything-- it bothers me a lot.
所以，特别是我住在新界。所以你周围的人，你听到的是普通话。然后你开始看到那些受教育程度较低的人。他们在街边蹲着。我确实目睹了一位大陆女士让她的孩子在路上小便。我总是听到大陆人在商场里大喊大叫，无缘无故地喊叫。而且总是，他们插队。所有这一切……这非常困扰我。
Squatting? What do you mean squatting?
蹲着？你说的蹲着是什么意思？
I don't know. They just squat on the roadside, waiting people.
我不知道。他们就蹲在路边等候。
They just sit and squat and wait.
他们只是坐着、蹲着，等着。
Yeah, for nothing. They can squat for an hour.
是的，无缘无故。他们可以蹲上一个小时。
People in Hong Kong don't do that.
香港人不这样做。
Yeah, we don't because who would squat at the road? Why you can't just stand? Or why you can't just sit?
是的，我们不，因为谁会蹲在马路上？为什么你不能站着？或者为什么你不能坐着？
They're more comfortable.
他们那样更舒服。
It just doesn't look good. It doesn't look good. It doesn't look civilized.
这看起来不好。看起来不文明。
So for all the alarm that Jennifer and the cursed generation feel about the future, their parents are often not as alarmed about China taking more control of Hong Kong and about what the island's going to be like in 2047. Like Tiffany's parents, they hate her going out to protests every weekend.
所以尽管詹妮弗和被诅咒的一代对未来感到担忧，但她们的父母对中国加强对香港的控制，以及2047年该岛会是什么样子，往往没有那么担心。就像蒂芙尼的父母，他们讨厌她每个周末出去抗议。
I mean, for my parents, they-- we really have some very serious fights.
我是说，对于我的父母，我们……我们确实有一些非常严重的争吵。
And they think, we'll just let China take over Hong Kong, it'll be fine?
他们认为，我们就让中国接管香港，会没事的？
I think with our parents, some of the older generation just don't believe, or they are not brave enough to open up their eyes and see what is actually going to happen. They just feel like they did not do anything wrong. As long as you did not do anything wrong, then you'll be fine.
我想对于我们的父母，一些老一辈人只是不相信，或者他们不够勇敢去睁开眼睛看看到底会发生什么。他们只是觉得他们没有做错任何事。只要你没有做错事，你就会没事。
What's galling about this for Tiffany is that she feels like she's being the responsible one, fighting for everybody's future. And they're telling her not to protest. She was like, maybe if her parents had done this themselves years ago, things wouldn't be so bad today.
对蒂芙尼来说，这最令她愤怒的是，她觉得自己在尽责任，为每个人的未来而战。而他们却告诉她不要抗议。她觉得，也许如果她父母多年前自己也这样做，今天就不会这么糟糕了。
I'm 22 years old. And in the past, when I was younger, they have never stood up like us or fight like us to ask for what they are promised in 1997.
我22岁了。而过去，当我更年轻时，他们从未像我们这样站出来，或像我们这样去要求1997年承诺给我们的东西。
It's funny. When you talk about it, you're mad at your parents about it.
很有趣。当你谈到这件事时，你对父母很生气。
I just feel like-- I mean, I don't understand why they would not want these rights or why they don't think that something bad is going to happen in the next 50 years.
我只是觉得……我是说，我不明白为什么他们不想拥有这些权利，或者为什么他们不认为未来50年会发生不好的事情。
So Tiffany and Jennifer and so many others, they've kind of given over their lives to protesting. They work during the week, protest on the weekends. They say they don't have much time in their lives for much else. But what's interesting is, they don't think it's going to work. Most of our interviewees told us that. They don't think China is going to give in. Again, here's Jennifer.
所以蒂芙尼和詹妮弗以及许多其他人，她们基本上把生命交给了抗议。她们周一到周五工作，周末抗议。她们说她们的生活中没多少时间做其他事情。但有趣的是，她们认为这不会起作用。我们大多数受访者都告诉我们这一点。她们不认为中国会退让。再次说明，这是詹妮弗。
I am pretty much pessimistic, actually. I do wish that one day, we all succeed. We want a democratic Hong Kong. But now, I just don't see a way out. It's been three months. We've been trying each and every step. We've broke into the legislative council. We have more than 1,000 people got arrested. But the government is still trying to ignore all of this.
实际上我很悲观。我确实希望有一天我们都能成功。我们想要一个民主的香港。但现在，我只是看不到出路。已经三个月了。我们尝试了每一步。我们闯入了立法会。我们有超过1000人被捕。但政府仍然试图忽略这一切。
If you feel so pessimistic about the results, why still go? Why are you still going out every weekend?
如果你对结果如此悲观，为什么还要去？为什么你仍然每个周末走出来？
At least the government sees that we are not that-- how do we say-- we are not that obedient. So we have to continuously tell the government that we are not satisfied with what they are giving us. So we have to do it.
至少政府看到我们不是那么……我们该怎么说……我们不是那么听话。所以我们必须不断告诉政府，我们对他们给我们的东西不满意。所以我们必须这样做。
Again, here's Alice.
再次说明，这是爱丽丝。
I think even if we have to lose, we need to leave our true thoughts in history. We need to let the people behind us know that we've tried.
我想即使我们必须失败，我们也需要在历史上留下我们真实的思想。我们需要让身后的人知道我们尝试过。
2047 is coming, and this is a very grand thing to say, but so many of these cursed generation kids feel like they have a special destiny. Alex preferred to speak to us through an interpreter. She's a frontline protester, builds barricades, has been arrested.
2047年即将来临，这是一个非常宏大的说法，但许多这些被诅咒一代的孩子觉得他们有一种特殊的命运。亚历克斯更喜欢通过翻译与我们交谈。她是一名一线抗议者，负责修筑路障，曾被逮捕。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[用中文说话]
I think we're actually lucky because we grew up with people who thought the same way. And we realized that when we turn 50, it's the end of our freedoms. I'm 22 now, and I imagine that when I'm 25, that's really halfway until the bomb explodes.
我觉得我们其实很幸运，因为我们和有同样想法的人一起成长。我们意识到当我们50岁时，就是我们自由的终点。我今年22岁，我想象当我有25岁时，那真的就是炸弹爆炸前的一半时间。
And so if we don't do anything, by the time we're 50 years old, it would be awful. I don't want our children to have the same battle. And then when we're 50, we'll look back and think that we didn't do enough. Our birthday is like a countdown to the end. And so, more so than other people, I feel like my generation, we have a duty to do more.
所以如果我们什么都不做，等到我们50岁时，那会很可怕。我不想让我们的孩子也经历同样的战斗。等到我们50岁时，我们会回头想我们做得不够。我们的生日就像是通向终点的倒计时。所以，比起其他人，我觉得我这一代有责任去做更多。
Again, here's Jennifer.
再次说明，这是詹妮弗。
If we were born earlier, probably I would become my dad and mom. And if I were born later, I would probably become those little kids speaking Mandarin better than Cantonese. So I am happy that I am born in 1997. We are in the middle. We have the chance to know what is freedom. And we are experiencing that our freedom is being taken away. And that's why we are the group who step up first to fight for it.
如果我们出生得更早，可能我会变成我的爸爸妈妈。如果我们出生得更晚，我可能就会变成那些说普通话比说广东话还好的小孩。所以我很高兴我是在1997年出生的。我们在中间。我们有机会知道什么是自由。而我们正在经历我们的自由被剥夺。这就是为什么我们是第一批站出来为之抗争的群体。
I think we are getting off here. I think we are getting off.
我想我们要在这里下车了。我想我们要下车了。
After an hour bus ride, we get to the protest. This is Act Two, The Fight. Once we're off the bus, Jennifer ducks into a public restroom and comes out in black shirt, black pants, black mask over her face, hair pulled back in a ponytail. And we head on to a street where we're surrounded by hundreds of people dressed exactly like her.
经过一小时的巴士车程，我们到达了抗议地点。这是第二幕，斗争。下了巴士后，詹妮弗钻进一个公共厕所，出来时换上了黑衬衫、黑裤子、脸上戴着黑色口罩，头发扎成马尾。我们走向一条街道，周围都是和她打扮一模一样的人。
A big shopping district, the stores closed, and no cars. All the side streets have been blocked off with barricades by the protesters-- scaffolding and fencing, trashcans, and orange construction cones piled in the street. They do an efficient job. We meet up with Jennifer's friends by a big Victoria's Secret store.
一个大型购物区，商店关门了，没有车。所有的侧街都被抗议者用路障封住了——脚手架、围栏、垃圾桶和堆在街上的橙色建筑锥。他们做得非常高效。我们在一家大型维多利亚的秘密商店旁边遇到了詹妮弗的朋友。
My friend, Hugo.
我的朋友，雨果。
Nice to meet you.
很高兴认识你。
Nice to meet you. Ira.
很高兴认识你。艾拉。
Nice to meet you, mate. Yes.
很高兴认识你，伙计。是的。
Very nice to meet you.
很高兴认识你。
The couple who always kiss in front of me.
那对总是当着我的面亲吻的情侣。
What? I'm not.
什么？我没有。
No, we didn't. We didn't.
不，我们没有。我们没有。
For the record, I'm with them all afternoon. No kissing at all. The city is giving permission for fewer protests these days. And this is an unsanctioned demonstration we're at, which means that everybody here is breaking the law. Anyone is subject to arrest, which affects crowd size. The maximum penalty is 5 years-- 10 years, if you're convicted of rioting-- which is why all the protesters are so scared of getting arrested all the time.
记录在案，我整个下午都和他们在一起。根本没有接吻。这些天政府允许的抗议越来越少了。我们所处的这是一场未获批准的示威活动，这意味着这里的每个人都在违法。任何人都可能被逮捕，这影响了人群的规模。最高刑罚是5年——如果是暴乱定罪则是10年——这就是为什么所有的抗议者都如此害怕一直被逮捕。
But despite that, the beginning of the protest has the feeling of a block party. People strolling, chatting-- you see a few parents and kids. Some non-protesters cut through the crowd, running errands. But an hour into all this, I look around and realize-- no families, no kids. It's not feeling like a block party at all. People are standing on top of fences, trying to see what's ahead of us. They're starting to put on gas masks.
但尽管如此，抗议开始时有一种街头派对的感觉。人们漫步、聊天——你看到几个父母带着孩子。一些非抗议者穿过人群，忙着办差事。但进入这一切一个小时后，我环顾四周意识到——没有家庭，没有孩子。它一点也不像街头派对。人们站在围栏上，试图看清前面有什么。他们开始戴上防毒面具。
Describe what you're seeing.
描述一下你看到的东西。
The protesters in the Thomas Street are moving backwards. So we assume that there are riot police on the other end of the road. There is tear gas fired over there.
托马斯街的抗议者正在向后移动。所以我们假设另一端有防暴警察。那边发射了催泪瓦斯。
It's like two or three blocks away. We walk towards the police and the tear gas, past teams of protesters who are knocking bricks out of the sidewalk with long steel tools.
大概有两个或三个街区远。我们走向警察和催泪瓦斯，经过一组组用长钢工具从人行道上敲下砖块的抗议者。
And the idea is what?
目的是什么？
To put on the road so, later on, the riot police cannot run that fast.
放到路上，这样防暴警察跑不快。
Also, people throw bricks at police. We march straight to the front lines, where hundreds of protesters are massed on a side street. The police are just half a block away, but we can't really see them through the crowd. And then a whole wave of tear gas canisters arcs towards us, hits us.
此外，人们向警察扔砖头。我们直接走向前线，那里有成百上千的抗议者聚集在侧街。警察就在半个街区之外，但我们透过人群看不清他们。接着，一波催泪瓦斯罐向我们射来，击中我们。
And lots of people, us included, run back a ways, half a block away. Jennifer calmly administers saline solution into strangers' eyes. The controls on my recorder got knocked around running through the smoke, so I do not have a decent recording of that.
包括我们在内的很多人向后跑了一段路，大约半个街区远。詹妮弗冷静地给陌生人的眼睛滴入生理盐水。我的录音机控制装置在浓烟中奔跑时被磕碰了，所以我没有那部分的清晰录音。
This is the role that she's assigned herself in the protests-- first aid, helping anybody who requires it. She even brought energy candy specifically to give out to people whose energy is flagging. After being driven back, Jennifer and her two friends and I wait for the smoke to clear.
这是她在抗议中给自己分配的角色——急救，帮助任何需要帮助的人。她甚至特意带了能量糖果分发给体力不支的人。在被驱赶后，詹妮弗和她的两个朋友以及我等待烟雾散去。
So this happens at every protest.
所以每次抗议都会发生这种情况。
Yes.
是的。
Basically.
基本上。
So what do we do now?
那我们现在该怎么办？
We tidy up ourselves and go again.
我们整理好自己，再来一次。
And when you get to the police, what are you going to do?
当你走到警察面前时，你会做什么？
We're going to stand in front of them. If we have a chance, we're going to fight them back. Our goal is to make them to reach their front line.
我们会站在他们面前。如果有机会，我们会回击他们。我们的目标是让他们到达他们的前线。
After a couple minutes, we head back toward the front line.
几分钟后，我们走向前线。
OK, we're walking forward to its corner, where it's this blue-- [COUGHS]
好的，我们正向前走去拐角处，那里是蓝色的……[咳嗽]
Take this out.
把这个拿出来。
And then we wait around.
然后我们就在附近等待。
Don't take it off.
别把它拿掉。
A water cannon goes off, blasting water that is dyed blue, laced with stuff that stings your skin. More tear gas, and we pull back a little. Then we move forward, wait again.
水炮车发射了，喷出染成蓝色、混合了刺痛皮肤物质的水。更多的催泪瓦斯，我们后退了一点。然后我们向前移动，再次等待。
This is both suspenseful and boring.
这既悬疑又无聊。
[LAUGHS] Sometimes there's not always a purpose. Sometimes we sitting at the back is just a support. We just add our support to those at the front.
[笑]有时并没有一个明确的目的。有时我们坐在后面只是支持。我们只是给我们前面的人增加支持。
Support like, if something happens, you'll do first aid?
支持是指，如果发生什么事，你会进行急救吗？
Something like this, but also, they know that there are many people behind them. It is important to give them some mental support as well. Yeah.
类似这样，但他们也知道后面有很多人。给他们一些精神上的支持也很重要。是的。
So many protesters are like Jennifer. They think it's their job to support the people at the front, who are the hardcore ones, who push back against police and throw Molotov cocktails and chase police with sticks and metal rods and tear stuff down to build barriers to slow the police, wearing full gear, helmets, goggles, and gas masks and gloves.
许多抗议者像詹妮弗一样。他们认为自己的工作是支持前线的人，那些硬核分子，他们抵御警察、扔燃烧瓶、用棍子和金属棒追赶警察、拆除东西来筑起屏障减缓警察的速度，戴着全套装备、头盔、护目镜、防毒面具和手套。
Finally, the front liners yell that they want room to retreat. And so we need to retreat. And so we fall way back, a couple blocks.
最终，前线的人大喊他们需要后撤的空间。所以我们需要后撤。于是我们向后退了好远，退了好几个街区。
So now we're just standing here.
所以现在我们就站在这里。
Yeah, because we always support. Our assistance is like a support to those in the front line.
是的，因为我们总是支持。我们的协助就像对前线的人的一种支持。
But I don't understand. So the police want us out of there. They push, they fire tear gas. They spray blue water on everybody. We move back. And then we stand here. And what's our goal?
但我还是不明白。警察想把我们赶走。他们推进，他们发射催泪瓦斯。他们对每个人喷蓝色水。我们后退。然后我们就站在这里。我们的目标是什么？
This has been a very frequently asked question. Nowadays, we're just trying to stand on our own ground, not to be dispersed that easily.
这是一个经常被问到的问题。如今，我们只是试图守住我们的阵地，不那么容易被驱散。
That's it. Just, the goal is to just stay out as long as you can.
就这些。目标仅仅是尽可能久地留在这里。
Yeah.
是的。
And then, eventually, the police will push you off the street? So in other words, it's exactly like the entire protest movement leading to 2047. Just try to slow them down as much as you can.
然后，最终，警察会把你从街上推开？换句话说，这完全就像通往2047年的整个抗议运动。只是尽量减缓他们的速度。
Yes.
是的。
In the end, China will win. But for as long as you can, you'll just stand here in the street.
最终，中国会赢。但只要你能，你就会站在这里的街上。
It is pretty sad to say so, but I guess that's pretty much accurate. Yeah, that's--
这么说很悲哀，但我猜这很准确。是的，那是……
What are they yelling?
他们在喊什么？
They ask people to start moving.
他们让人们开始移动。
And there we headed to a massive retreat, as the police advanced towards us. And for the first time, there seems to be actual real fear. We're running down streets and side roads. We get separated from Jennifer's friends and from Emanuele, dodging the police, and finally, taking refuge in a church. There are safe houses like this around Hong Kong that protesters duck into.
随之我们开始了大规模后撤，警察向我们推进。这是第一次，似乎出现了真正的恐惧。我们在街道和小路上奔跑。我们和詹妮弗的朋友以及伊曼纽尔走散了，躲避警察，最终躲进了一座教堂。香港各地都有像这样的避难所供抗议者躲藏。
It takes over an hour, and finally, the coast is clear. And Jennifer calls a friend to pick her up. They're volunteer drivers for the protesters, part of the infrastructure they've created. Jennifer changes out of her black T-shirt into civilian clothes. No makeup-- she's too tired, she says. And no need if she's getting picked up.
花了一个多小时，海岸终于安全了。詹妮弗打电话给一个朋友来接她。他们是抗议者的志愿者司机，是他们创造的基建的一部分。詹妮弗把黑色T恤换成了平民衣服。没有化妆——她说她太累了。而且如果有人来接她，也没必要化妆。
Bye.
再见。
And she heads home.
她回家了。
Say goodbye to Emanuele for me as well. Thank you.
也替我向伊曼纽尔说再见。谢谢。
[SIRENS]
[警笛声]
Coming up, we hear from people in Hong Kong who welcome China's takeover of the city with open arms and how one of them came to feel that way. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，我们将听到香港欢迎中国接管这座城市的人们的声音，以及其中一个人是如何产生这种感觉的。那将在从芝加哥公共广播电台传来的节目继续后的一分钟内播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, we are returning to a program that we first broadcast this past fall about the protests in Hong Kong. I traveled to Hong Kong with my co-workers, Diane Wu and Emanuele Berry.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们回到去年秋天我们首次广播的关于香港抗议的节目。我和我的同事黛安·吴、伊曼纽尔·贝里去了香港。
Under the new national security law that China put into effect a couple weeks ago in Hong Kong, many of the things that these protesters said to us back then that you are hearing this hour could theoretically be prosecuted. We have changed nearly everybody's name.
在中国几周前于香港生效的新国家安全法下，这些抗议者当时对我们说的许多话，你这一个小时里听到的内容，理论上都可能受到起诉。我们更改了几乎所有人的名字。
We will end the show today with an interview that I did this month about that law with Jennifer, who you heard in the first half of the show. For now, we have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Good Cop, Dad Cop.
今天节目结束时，我们将播放我本月就该法律与詹妮弗进行的一次采访，她在节目上半部分出现过。现在，我们来到了我们节目的第三幕。第三幕，好警察，爸爸警察。
So as an American visiting Hong Kong for the first time, one of the things that kind of killed me was hearing that, before the last few years of protests, people were really into the police. They were trusted. They were respected.
作为一名第一次访问香港的美国人，让我感到震惊的一件事是听说，在最近几年抗议之前，人们真的很喜欢警察。他们是受信任、受尊重的。
And it was only in the last few years, especially the last few months of protests, that changed all that. At a rally, I actually saw people chanting at a row of cops that they hoped that they and their families would die. And feelings about who to side with-- the police or the protesters-- they've gotten so intense, it's tearing families apart.
而正是最近几年，特别是最近几个月抗议活动，改变了这一切。在一次集会上，我甚至看到人们对一排警察高呼希望他们和他们的家人去死。关于支持谁——警察还是抗议者——的感受，已经变得如此强烈，以至于正在撕裂家庭。
On the Telegram app, there's a whole channel for protesters who get kicked out by their parents and need a place to live. Alan Yu grew up in Hong Kong. He knows a family that is very far apart on this. The son is a protester. The dad is a retired police officer.
在Telegram应用程序上，有一个专门为被父母赶出家门需要地方住的抗议者开设的频道。艾伦·俞在香港长大。他认识一个家庭，他们的分歧非常巨大。儿子是抗议者。父亲是退休警察。
And Alan had them sit down and do what nobody in Hong Kong is doing-- talk to each other. There is really no dialogue between police and protesters anywhere in Hong Kong, as far as we could tell.
艾伦让他们坐下来做香港没有人做的事情——交谈。据我们所知，在香港任何地方，警察和抗议者之间真的没有对话。
And can I say, listening to this story today, nine months after we first broadcast it, after weeks of protests against police violence across the United States, I really do wonder how common this kind of experience is in our country. Anyway, here's Alan.
我能说的是，在首次广播九个月后，在美国各地的抗议警察暴力的抗议活动之后，今天听这个故事，我真的怀疑这种经历在我国有多普遍。不管怎样，这是艾伦。
I've known this family since I was six. I knew them because of my friend, Jonathan. I rode the school bus with him every day. His father, Peter, was the first policeman I knew in real life. I was excited to talk to him because you never hear what the police think about the protests. Police here are not really allowed to talk to the press.
我从六岁起就认识这个家庭了。我认识他们是因为我的朋友乔纳森。我和他每天一起坐校车。他的父亲彼得是我在现实生活中认识的第一个警察。我很高兴和他谈谈，因为你从来没有听到警察对这些抗议活动的看法。这里的警察其实不允许接受媒体采访。
Peter's retired, but still very connected to the force. So before the family all sat down together, I asked Peter to get together with me and my producer, Emanuele. I hadn't seen him since I was 12. Back then, people called me "Yu-don," which means fish ball. Because the Cantonese for fish sounds like my surname, Yu, and because I was fat.
彼得退休了，但与警队仍有联系。所以在这个家庭坐在一起之前，我请彼得和我和我的制作人伊曼纽尔见了个面。我从12岁起就没见过他了。那时，人们叫我“鱼蛋”，意思是鱼丸。因为广东话里的鱼听起来像我的姓氏俞，也因为我很胖。
I won't recognize you on the street. I won't. I won't.
我在街上认不出你。我不会的。我不会。
Oh, yeah? Oh, OK.
哦，是吗？哦，好的。
Serious. I'm serious.
认真的。我是认真的。
OK, all right. I guess it's a compliment. Thank you.
好的，好吧。我想这是一种恭维。谢谢。
He used to be very cute.
他以前很可爱。
Yeah? How?
是吗？怎么说？
He used to be very fat.
他以前很胖。
As a kid, I liked Peter. He'd take time off work to stop by during recess and buy us chips and other snacks. My friend Jonathan would have his birthday parties at the police station, which we loved-- big barbecues, other policemen around. Peter was the cool dad.
小时候，我喜欢彼得。他会请假在课间休息时来看我们，给我们买薯片和其他零食。我的朋友乔纳森会在警察局举行生日派对，那是我们最喜欢的——大型烧烤，其他警察也在场。彼得是那个酷爸爸。
People in Hong Kong trusted, even revered the police back then. One of the most popular TV shows was a cop show, [CHINESE], where the police were heroes. Peter's hair is gray now. He's tall, athletic. He plays tennis.
那时香港人信任甚至崇拜警察。最受欢迎的电视节目之一是警匪剧，警察是英雄。彼得现在头发花白。他身材高大，热爱运动。他打网球。
My nickname in tennis-- I don't know why. My nickname in tennis is Federer. Yeah.
我的网球昵称——我不知道为什么。我的网球昵称是费德勒。是的。
Federer.
费德勒。
Oh, are you good?
哦，你打得好吗？
Federer Roger. I don't know why. Maybe my skill. I don't know. I don't know why. [CHUCKLES]
费德勒·罗杰。我不知道为什么。也许是因为我的技术。我不知道。我不知道为什么。[轻笑]
He still likes his dad jokes. I cannot imagine Peter ever doing what I've been seeing in these videos-- beating up unarmed protesters, kicking people on the ground. I thought surely he would object to some of those things and that his views would be complicated.
他仍然喜欢他的冷笑话。我无法想象彼得会做出我在这些视频中看到的事——殴打手无寸铁的抗议者，踢地上的人。我确信他会反对其中的一些事情，他的观点会很复杂。
From what you've seen in recent months, has there been anything that the police have done that you think you would disagree with?
从你近几个月看到的，警察做的有什么你认为不同意的事情吗？
Nothing is perfect. But as a whole, in general, I think the police are doing a pretty good job. If it is in other police force in other countries, just look at the casualties. Just look at the column of fatal numbers. It won't be zero.
没有什么是完美的。但总的来说，我认为警察做得很好。如果是其他国家的其他警察部队，看看伤亡人数。看看死亡人数。那不会是零。
I ask him about different situations the police have been criticized for. I even show him videos of police brutally arresting people, things I think are clearly wrong. But he always seems to have a justification for the way police behave. He says, you're judging the police based on what you see in these clips. That's not fair. You don't know what the officer was facing.
我问他关于警察受到批评的不同情况。我甚至给他看警察粗暴逮捕人的视频，我认为那是明显错误的。但他似乎总是为警察的行为方式找借口。他说，你是在根据你看到的这些片段来评判警察。那是不公平的。你不知道那位警官当时面临什么。
The social media only show the part of police hitting people. But one minute ago, they've been attacked by lots of people. So one minute later, he react to the mob attacking them. So what you can see is one minute after, but you did not see the full picture.
社交媒体只显示警察打人的那一面。但一分钟前，他们遭到了很多人的攻击。所以一分钟后，他反击攻击他们的暴徒。所以你能看到的是一分钟后，但你没有看到全貌。
He's not conflicted about police. And he isn't very sympathetic to the protesters. He thinks the protests are destroying Hong Kong. The extradition bill is OK. He doesn't think China will end free speech in Hong Kong. And protesters' fear of China is way overblown and naive.
他对警察没有冲突感。而且他不太同情抗议者。他认为抗议活动正在摧毁香港。引渡法案没问题。他不认为中国会结束香港的言论自由。抗议者对中国的恐惧被过度夸大和天真了。
Hong Kong is part of China. Come on. Wake up. People, wake up. This is the fact. Whether China is good or bad, Hong Kong is part of China. If you don't like it, those people waving the United States flag, waving the Union Jack flag, if England takes you, you can go to England. Yeah. You can go to Florida. Go to California. Yeah. Go, go. If Trump takes you, yeah, go.
香港是中国的一部分。得了吧。醒醒。人们，醒醒。这是事实。不管中国好还是坏，香港是中国的一部分。如果你不喜欢，那些挥舞美国旗帜、挥舞英国国旗的人，如果英国接管你，你可以去英国。是的。你可以去佛罗里达。去加利福尼亚。是的。去吧，去吧。如果特朗普接管你，是的，去吧。
I'd already been worried how this family conversation was going to go. Hearing what Peter believed did not help. Peter told me he understands that Jonathan goes to protests, but doesn't ask him about it because he doesn't want any details. Jonathan said he does not ask his dad what he thinks of the way police beat and tear gassed protesters for the same reason.
我之前就很担心这次家庭谈话会怎么样。听彼得相信的东西并没有帮助。彼得告诉我他理解乔纳森去抗议，但他不想问他细节，因为他不想知道详情。乔纳森说他也不问他父亲关于警察如何殴打和催泪瓦斯对付抗议者的看法，原因也是一样。
It's just like, if he says something-- [SIGHS] if he says something that completely doesn't make sense to me, it sort of brings him down as a person. It's just like, I would feel like he's just, yeah, not who I thought he was, yeah.
就像是，如果他说些什么……[叹气]如果他说的话对我来说完全没道理，这会让他整个人在我心目中的形象下降。就像是，我会觉得他只是……是的，不是我以为的那种人。
And it scares you to--
想到那可能是真的让你感到害怕。
Yeah.
是的。
--think that could be true.
所以这个家庭根本不谈论抗议。网球，可以。足球，可以。宠物，很好。但没有政治——直到今晚。他们在晚餐后同意进行他们一直在避免的谈话。乔纳森的母亲阿尔娃在洗碗。
So this family does not talk about the protests at all. Tennis, yes. Soccer, yes. Pets, great. But no politics-- till tonight. They've agreed to have the conversation they've been avoiding after dinner. Jonathan's mom, Alva, washes the dishes.
[阿尔娃在哼歌]
[ALVA HUMMING]
我立刻认出了这首歌。我很惊讶她在彼得面前哼唱这首歌。这是抗议者的新赞歌，《愿荣光归香港》。阿尔娃站在乔纳森那边。她和律师一起工作，包括一些民主派的律师。
I recognize the song right away. I'm surprised she's humming it in front of Peter. It's the protesters' new anthem, "Glory to Hong Kong." Alva is on Jonathan's side. She works with lawyers, including some in the pro-democracy camp.
我问彼得知不知道那首歌是什么。她说，也许吧。她和她丈夫之间大概就是那样的情况。没有真正的讨论，只是在看新闻时偶尔发表被动的攻击性评论，或者在洗碗时哼唱被动的攻击性歌曲。这也是乔纳森避免提及抗议活动的另一个原因。他不想在他父母之间引发争吵。
I ask if Peter knows what that song is. She says, maybe. That's kind of how it's been going between her and her husband. No real discussion, but the occasional passive-aggressive comment while they're watching the news, or some passive-aggressive humming during dishes. This is another reason Jonathan avoids bringing up the protests. He doesn't want to start a fight between his parents.
最坏的情况会是什么样？
What would the worst scenario be like?
有人搬出去住，我想。是的，因为他们受不了了。是的，我想分居将是最坏的情况。因为那在某种程度上意味着你们不再在一起了。
Someone moving out, I guess. Yeah, because they can't stand it anymore. Yeah, I guess, living apart would be the worst case scenario, I believe. Because that sort of unofficially means that you're no longer together, sort of, yeah.
那可能是他妈妈，或他爸爸，或他自己。
That could be his mom, or his dad, or him.
我们都坐在餐桌旁。我不知道他们为什么同意谈论这个。也许只是因为我认识他们太久了，而且我问了。或者我希望也许他们的一部分人想谈，而我只是一个很好的借口。
We all sit at the dinner table. I don't know why they agreed to talk about this. Maybe just because I've known them for so long, and I asked. Or I hope maybe part of them wanted to talk, and I was just a good excuse.
彼得面对着我。乔纳森和阿尔娃在我旁边。乔纳森怀里抱着他们的狗，以漫威角色命名的洛基。谈话开始时，他们都以不同的方式说，我们不谈论这个很好。我们都有相互尊重。
Peter's facing me. And Jonathan and Alva are next to me. Jonathan has their dog, Loki, named after the Marvel character, on his lap. The conversation starts with all of them saying, in different ways, it's fine that we don't talk about this. We all have mutual respect.
他们不是互相交谈或看着对方，而是和我交谈或看着狗。感觉一切都非常小心、得体和平静。这种情况持续了半个小时。然后当彼得使用“妥协”这个词时，一切都变了。
Instead of talking to each other or looking at each other, they're talking to me or looking at the dog. It feels all very careful, proper, and calm. This continues for half an hour. Then everything changes when Peter uses the word "compromise."
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
妥协——这基本上是政府的路线。这就是香港行政长官林郑月娥所说的，抗议者应该停止抗议。在那之后，双方可以谈。阿尔娃和乔纳森听到的意思是抗议者应该退缩。他们都开始攻击彼得。
Compromise-- it's basically the government line. That's what Hong Kong's chief executive Carrie Lam says, that the protesters should stop protesting. And after that, the two sides can talk. Alva and Jonathan hear that as meaning the protesters should back down. They both lay into Peter.
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
阿尔娃说警察才是需要改变的人。他们必须平息局势。彼得说警察是在做他们的工作。我不知道为什么，当警察逮捕因打架或破坏东西的人时，它被视为奇怪的。这是非法的，所以逮捕他们。没问题。
Alva says the police are the ones who need to change. They have to calm the situation. Peter says the police are doing their job. I don't know why, when the police arrest people for fighting or breaking stuff, it's treated as weird. It's illegal, so arrest them. No problem.
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
乔纳森说，好的，是的，逮捕他们。但警察需要使用多少武力？有时一个人只是问警察一个问题，他们仍然被逮捕或殴打。或者已经在地上、跪着、被制服的人，他们仍然被殴打。彼得没有回应。
Johnson says, OK, yes, arrest them. But how much force does the police need to use? Sometimes a person just asks the police a question, and they still get arrested or beaten. Or people who are already on the ground, kneeling, subdued, they still get beaten. Peter doesn't respond.
然后他们争论，第一次公开争论抗议者的主要要求之一，政府拒绝让步的事情——启动对警察行为的独立调查。
Then they argue, openly argue for the first time, about one of the protesters' main demands, something the government refused to budge on-- to start an independent investigation into police behavior.
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
彼得一遍又一遍地重复同样的话，就像他被逼到墙角一样，不需要独立调查。现在不是合适的时机。
Peter keeps repeating the same thing over and over, like he's been backed into a corner, that there's no need for independent investigation. Now is not the right time.
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
城市已经有一个系统来调查针对警察的投诉。
The city already has a system in place to investigate complaints about the police.
[用中文说话]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
他们又谈了一会儿，但没有任何进展。阿尔娃后来告诉我，她还有其他可以提出的事情，但决定不提了。她不想让她的丈夫感到陷入困境。她使用的词是“死角”，翻译为没有去路。对她来说，维护家庭比试图赢得争论更重要。
They talk a little longer, but it doesn't go anywhere. Alva tells me later she had other things she could have brought up, but decided against it. She didn't want her husband to feel trapped. The word she used was [CHINESE], which translates as dead corner. No place to go. Preserving the family was more important to her than trying to win an argument.
后来，乔纳森告诉我他仍然爱他的父亲。但他已经放弃了父亲能成为一个理智的人的希望，至少在警察方面是这样。
Later, Jonathan told me he still loves his dad. But he's given up hope that his father could be a reasonable human being, at least when it comes to the police.
当我开始做这个时，我有点天真。我以为也许乔纳森和他的母亲和父亲，真正想互相理解的人，能以一种富有成效的方式谈论这一点，如果他们能，也许我们其他人也有希望。但现在，我没有太多的希望。
When I started this, I was kind of naive. I thought maybe Jonathan and his mother and father, people who actually want to understand each other, could talk about this in a productive manner, and that if they could, maybe there was hope that the rest of us could. But now, I don't have a lot of hope.
艾伦·俞，他通常是WHYY节目《脉搏》的记者。乔纳森、他的兄弟克里斯和阿尔娃现在正在认真考虑离开香港。彼得没有。
Alan Yu, he's normally a reporter for WHYY's show, The Pulse. Jonathan, his brother, Chris, and Alva are now thinking seriously about leaving Hong Kong. Peter is not.
第四幕，通往中国的慢船。那么那些生活在香港对中国没有问题，喜欢中国的人呢？他们有很多。他们举行自己的示威活动，规模相当小——快闪派对，快闪族出现在商场挥舞中国国旗，唱中国国歌。
Act Four, A Slow Boat to China. So what about all the people living in Hong Kong who have no problem with China, who like China? There's a lot of them. And they hold their own demonstrations, which are pretty small-- flag parties where flash mobs show up at malls and wave Chinese flags and sing the Chinese national anthem.
庆祝中国的重大日子通常是10月1日，国庆节，共产党建立现代中国国家的周年纪念日。今年将是一个大日子。这是70周年。
And the big day to celebrate China normally would be October 1, National Day, the anniversary of the Communist Party founding the modern Chinese state. And this year was going to be a big one. It was the 70th anniversary.
支持中国大陆的人有点愤慨，因为这一天本应是他们盛大的节日，但预计会有大规模抗议，城市关闭了。烟花被取消。列车停运。几乎所有的商场都要关门。抗议者又毁了这一天。
And the people who support mainland China were kind of resentful, because this day was supposed to be this huge holiday for them, but anticipating massive protests, the city shut down. Fireworks were canceled. Trains weren't running. Almost all the malls were going to be closed. The protesters had ruined the day again.
因此，为了挑战，亲中人士组织了一个赞歌演唱派对，在1号上午举行。我们的同事黛安·吴去了。
So in defiance, the pro-China people organized an anthem singing party for the morning of the first. Our co-worker, Diane Wu, went.
派对在早上8:30的一艘船上举行。不只是一艘普通的船——在天星小轮上，这艘标志性的香港通勤兼观光船在海港上。这些轮渡是殖民时代的这些美丽的旧船，名字叫银星、北星、闪烁星。今天，其中一艘将被亮红色的中国国旗完全覆盖。
The party took place at 8:30 in the morning on a boat. Not just any boat-- on the Star Ferry, this iconic Hong Kong commuter slash sightseeing boat on the harbor. The ferries are these beautiful old boats from colonial times with names like Silver Star, Northern Star, Twinkling Star. And today, one of them is going to get completely covered with bright red Chinese flags.
大约有两打人聚集在码头。他们大多是陌生人，从之前的快闪族和聚会中大致互相认识。
A couple dozen people are gathering at the ferry terminal. They're mostly strangers, know each other loosely from previous flash mobs and get-togethers.
[用中文大喊]
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
“我爱中国，”他们喊道。
"I love China," they shout.
[用中文大喊]
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
“支持警察。”
"Support the police."
[用中文大喊]
[SHOUTING IN CHINESE]
[欢呼]
[CHEERING]
当你想到这一点时其实挺有趣的，所有这些人都在休息日这么早就起床，上一艘船一起唱国歌。这也有一点黑暗，因为存在着针对不支持抗议的人的真实暴力威胁。
It's kind of funny when you think about it, all these people up so early on their day off, getting on a boat to sing the national anthem together. It's also a little dark, because there's a real threat of violence against people who don't support the protest.
两周前在商场里这些旗帜派对中的一个演变成了一场斗殴，当抗议者出现时。双方的人都受到了殴打。所以去轮渡上喊亲中口号是战略性的。一旦你在海上的船上，你应该就能免受反抗议者的攻击。正如一个人所说……
One of these flag parties two weeks ago at a mall devolved into a brawl when protesters showed up. People on both sides got beat up. And so going out on a ferry to shout pro-China slogans is strategic. Once you're on the boat out at sea, you ought to be safe from a counter protest. As one guy put it--
嗯，过去三个月我们一直生活在恐怖中，因为另一边的人，暴徒，他们真的很擅长恐怖策略。他们让你觉得你应该害怕大声说话并公开反对他们，因为他们组织得太好了。
Well, we've been living in terror for the last three months because the people on the other side, the rioters, they're really good at the terrorizing tactics. They make you feel that you should be afraid of speaking up and speaking out against them because they're so organized.
在候船厅里，大家围成半圆，拿着特别的中国日报假期特刊，一起唱中国国歌。
In the terminal, everyone gathers in a semicircle, holding special holiday issues of the China Daily and singing the Chinese national anthem together.
[用中文唱歌]
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
唱得有点不稳。带头的那个人告诉我他两周前才学会歌词。据我所知，这里的大多数人，不是从小唱着赞歌长大的大陆人。我交谈过的那些人都是香港人。如此热爱中国对他们来说是新鲜事，只有当抗议变得足够糟糕以至于他们发现自己聚集在这面新旗帜周围时才发生。
It's a little shaky. The guy leading it told me he just learned the words a couple weeks ago. Most of the people here, best as I can tell, are not mainlanders who grew up with the anthem. The ones I talked to were all from Hong Kong. Being this into China is new for them, something that only happened when the protests got bad enough that they found themselves rallying around this new flag.
而且这并不总是舒服。我和丹尼尔一起上船时，那个抱怨被恐怖主义的人，当有人在他身上贴了一个心形贴纸时。
And it's not always comfortable. I'm getting on the boat with Daniel, the guy who was griping about being terrorized, when someone puts a heart-shaped sticker on him.
你刚被贴上了一张中国国旗贴纸。
You just got a Chinese flag sticker stuck on you.
是的，是的。我对此感觉有点尴尬。
Yes, yeah. I feel a little cringey about this.
为什么？
Why?
我没那么红。与这里很多人相比，我不是最红的那个人。
I'm not exactly that red. Compared to a lot of people here, I'm not the most red person.
红，在香港抗议的蜡笔盒里，指的是亲中，蓝指政府，黄指抗议者。丹尼尔其实差点今天早上没来。这真的不是他的场景。他认为如此爱国地对待中国有点愚蠢。而且……
Red, in the crayon box of the Hong Kong protests, refers to being pro-China, versus blue for the government and yellow for the protesters. Daniel almost didn't come this morning, actually. It's not really his scene. He sees being this patriotic about China as kind of dorky. Moreover--
我总是告诉我的朋友我永远不想住在中国，因为如果我被迫住在中国，中国有很多我不接受的事情。
I always tell my friends I would never want to live in China, because there's a lot of things in China that I can't accept if I were to be forced to live in China.
他不能接受的两件事，我们最终谈论的是缺乏言论自由和对互联网的审查访问。
The two things he can't accept that we end up talking about are the lack of free speech and censored access to the internet.
但事实是，我住在香港。而且我能在接下来的28年里保留我几乎不受限制的自由。这对香港人来说真是一笔甜蜜的交易。
But the truth is, I live in Hong Kong. And I get to retain my almost unchecked freedom for 28 more years. And it's such a sweetheart deal for Hong Kong people.
我向他指出，28年后，这些自由很有可能消失。他作出了和我从其他不喜欢抗议的人那里听到的同样的反应。他说，嗯，当然，也许吧。
I pointed out to him that after 28 years, it's very possible those freedoms would disappear. And he had the same response that I heard from other people who don't like the protests. He was like, well, sure, maybe.
嗯，我想，你是在说服我欣赏年轻人的观点，但作为交换他们争取的自由，他们在造成严重破坏，他们在摧毁法律和秩序。而且……
Well, I guess, you're talking me to appreciate the young people's perspectives, but in exchange for the freedom that they fight for, they're wreaking havoc, and they're destroying law and order. And--
所以权衡之下，这对你不值得。
So in the balance, it's not worth it to you.
如果我要在这两者之间做出选择——如果中国说，为了有法律和秩序，我需要像中国人在香港那样牺牲自由，我会接受那种平衡。这是不可接受的，整个混乱的革命，以及他们在香港造成的严重破坏。这完全不可接受。我会像在中国那样放弃自由来停止这一切。
If I were to choose between this-- if China say, in order to have law and order, I will need to sacrifice the freedom the same way Chinese people have in Hong Kong, I would accept that balance. This is unacceptable, the whole unorganized chaos, revolution, and the havoc they wrought in Hong Kong. It's completely unacceptable. I will give up the freedom the way they do in China to stop this.
从“我永远不能住在中国”到“我会牺牲我的自由只是为了让这停止”是一个巨大的跨越。但抗议活动的强度和他对在城市中所经历的一切的挫败感，促使他至少尝试这种极端的想法。
It's a big jump from I could never live in China to I would sacrifice my freedom just to get this to stop. But the intensity of the protests and his frustration with what he's experiencing in the city have driven him to at least try on this extreme idea.
丹尼尔40岁，从事金融工作。他在美国住了12年。他是足球迷。支持芝加哥熊队，因为他喜欢他们顽强的防守。他说在此之前他没有参与政治。去年春天参加过一次大型和平抗议，更多是为了观察而不是参与。
Daniel's 40, works in finance. He lived in the US for 12 years. He's a football fan. Roots for the Chicago Bears because he likes the tenacious defense. He says he wasn't politically involved before all this. Went to one of the big peaceful protests last spring, more to watch than to participate.
但这在他有一天观看年轻抗议者冲击立法会的直播时改变了。他很惊讶他们看起来那么凶猛，甚至警察看起来也有点害怕。
But that changed one day when he was watching a livestream of the young protesters storming the legislative council. He was surprised how ferocious they seemed, how even the police officers looked a little scared.
那一刻，我突然意识到，哦，我们其实非常接近革命。它可能发生。香港会经历这些，我从来没想过。这既是震惊也是对未知的焦虑，你知道，焦虑。事情会突然改变。如果没有革命，它将迫使中国政府暴力镇压它。
At that moment, I suddenly realized, oh, we're actually very close to a revolution. It could happen. It's just never occurred to me that Hong Kong would go through that. It's both stunned and anxiety about unknown, you know, anxiety. Things can change abruptly. If there isn't a revolution, it's going to force the hand of the Chinese government to crack down on it violently.
而且任何事情都可能发生。我可能会失去我作为香港公民拥有的所有特权——普通法的保护、言论自由，以及受普通法保护的言论自由。在中国没有人享有这种自由。但如果它达到了某一点，我们可以失去所有这些我珍视的特权。
And anything can happen. I could lose all the privilege I have as a Hong Kong citizen-- protection of common law, freedom of speech, but also freedom of speech protected by common law. Nobody in China enjoy this freedom. But if it gets to a certain point, we can lose all of these privileges, which I treasure.
他第二天早上醒来看到报道铺天盖地全是关于警察暴力的。对丹尼尔来说，似乎每个人都忽略了抗议者是发起者这一事实，这对警察来说似乎极不公正。
He woke up the next morning to see that the coverage was wall-to-wall about police brutality. To Daniel, it seemed like everyone was leaving out the fact that the protesters had started it, which seemed deeply unjust to the police.
就在那时我开始变蓝。当我感到警察被不公平地抹黑时，我站在他们一边。我选择站在警察这边。
And that's when I started turning blue. When I felt that the police were smeared unfairly, I took my side. I chose to be on the police side.
其他人出于不同的原因站在抗议的对立面。我听到的一个主要原因是他们造成的干扰。保安告诉我，有一天因为地铁关闭，他不得不转四次车才能回家。
Other people sided against the protest for different reasons. A big one I heard was the disruption they caused. The security guard told me he had to transfer four times to get home one night because of subway shutdowns.
一位试图从被抗议者摧毁的自动取款机里取钱的妇女说，如果你对政府生气，那就去政府那里撒气。你只是在伤害像我这样的人。一个男人悲伤地对我说，香港是我们的家。为什么他们在摧毁它？
A woman trying to get cash out of an ATM that had been destroyed by protesters said, if you're mad at the government, take it out on the government. You're only hurting people like me. A man said to me, sadly, Hong Kong is our home. Why are they destroying it?
[用中文唱歌]
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
[欢呼]
[CHEERING]
船上的人群第二次唱完国歌，突然间，大家都冲向栏杆。
The crowd on the boat finishes belting out the national anthem a second time, when, suddenly, everyone rushes to the railing.
每个人都在向海上警察挥手。他们全跑到船的一侧。感觉它可能要翻了。
Everyone's waving at the sea police. They all ran to one side of the boat. It feels like it might tip over.
大家挤在船的一侧，姿势有点不稳定。那有点像丹尼尔现在的世界。他感到被迫选择一个团队。不管喜不喜欢，这些人是他现在的一群人。他不完全像他们那样思考。
Everyone crammed together on one side in a position that's a little precarious. That's kind of like Daniel's world right now. He felt pushed to choose a team. Like it or not, these are his new people. He doesn't think like them exactly.
但他觉得与船上这些挥手向警察致意的中国民族主义者相比，与围攻他们的愤怒抗议者更一致，即使那些抗议者最终想要的和他想要的一样——保留他们在香港的自由。
But he feels more aligned with these Chinese nationalists on this boat, waving at the police, than with the angry protesters ganging up on them, even if those protesters ultimately want the same thing he does-- to preserve their freedoms in Hong Kong.
[用中文唱歌]
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
坐在天星小轮的上层甲板，这其实是丹尼尔第一次在公共场合唱国歌。他后来告诉我，当他唱的时候，他惊讶地发现他有所触动。
Sitting on the upper deck of the Star Ferry, this was actually the first time Daniel had ever sang the national anthem in public. He told me later, as he sang, he was surprised to find that he felt something.
黛安·吴。她上周和丹尼尔谈过。随着国家安全法的通过，他指责抗议者杀死了他所珍视的香港，但说他接受这是唯一可行的未来。顺便说一下，他发现法律通过时做的第一件事之一就是把Facebook头像改回他的真名。现在他感到受保护，免受暴徒侵害。
Diane Wu. She talked to Daniel last week. With the passing of the national security law, he blames the protesters for killing the Hong Kong that he cherished, but says he accepts it as the only viable future. One of the first things, by the way, that he did when he found out about the law passing was change his Facebook profile back to his real name. Now he feels protected from the mob.
第五幕，九个月后。正如我们所说，中国对香港的新国家安全法本月生效。如果你想在技术上细究的话，是在那个月开始前一小时。
Act 5, Nine Months Later. So as we've said, China's new national security law for Hong Kong went into effect this month. Or if you want to get technical about it, one hour before the month began.
那个月进入第二天时，我联系了詹妮弗，你在节目上半部分听到的那个抗议者。她告诉我，自从我们秋天录制她之后，抗议活动规模变小了很多，完全不像我们当时目睹的那样。
And two days into the month, I reached Jennifer, the protester that you heard in the first half of the show. She told me that since we recorded her in the fall, protests have gotten a lot smaller, nothing like what we witnessed back then.
她说她一直在抗议，但频率降低了，也许一个月一次左右。她告诉我，她曾想过有一天中国可能会像这样进行镇压，就像这部新法律一样。她只是没想到会这么快。她以为在任何异见表达被惩罚之前，他们还有几年的时间。
And she has kept protesting, she said, but less often, maybe once a month or so. She told me that she had thought that China might crack down some day like this, like it did with the new law. She just didn't expect it so soon. She thought they had years before any expression of dissent could be punished, like it can right now.
我脑子里想到的第一件事就是，哦，天哪。终于来了。老实说，感觉太……感觉太绝望了，我们什么也做不了来阻止这一切再发生。
The first thing that came into my mind was, oh my God. This is finally coming. And to be honest, it felt so-- it felt so hopeless and we could not do anything to stop this from happening anymore.
是的。你注意到这个城市已经有变化了吗，比如餐厅和标志、海报之类的？
Yeah. Have you noticed changes in the city already, like at restaurants and signs and posters and things like that?
所以我正在……我刚下巴士。我正走在回家的路上。现在我在回家的路上看到的，到处都挂着中国旗和香港旗，周围有横幅和海报，写着……支持国家安全法。这就是我基本上看到的改变。
So I am on my-- I just got off the bus. And I am walking on my way going back home. Now what I'm seeing on my way back to home, everywhere is hanging with China and also Hong Kong flag, with banners and posters around, saying-- supporting the national security law. So that's what I've seen basically changing.
那中国国旗，三天前就在那里吗？
And the Chinese flag, was it there three days ago?
我昨天没看到。它昨天不在那里。但中国国旗昨天不在那里。然后现在我们有很多国旗在那里。就像他们试图支持政府的决定一样。
I didn't see it yesterday. It wasn't there yesterday. But the Chinese flag was not there yesterday. And then now we have a lot of them there. Like they are trying to support the government's decision.
那让你感觉如何？
And how does that make you feel?
哦，真的就像我们不能再对政府说任何话了。那个反对政府的一方不得不消失。然后未来这个城市只会有一种声音和一种思维。所以这其实有点悲哀。
Oh, just really like we cannot say anything against the government anymore. The side that is fighting against the government has to disappear. And then there will be only one opinion and one type of thinking in this city in the future. So it is kind of sad, actually.
你还会去抗议吗？
Will you still go to protest?
我想这真的取决于抗议是为了什么，以及安全法未来将如何实施和使用。我想我还需要一段时间来观察它实际上是如何被付诸行动的。
I think it really depends on what kind of the protest is for and how the security law will be implemented and used in the future. I think it will still take me a period of time to observe how it is being actually taken into action.
我不知道该说什么。我现在还不想放弃。我仍然希望有机会改变一些事情。但对我来说，法律才通过了一天。还有许多未知的变化。所以在我内心深处，我仍然希望能出去参加抗议……也许有机会改变一些事情。但老实说，我真的不知道未来是否还能出去。
I don't know what to say. I don't want to give up at this moment yet. I still hope that there will be a chance to change something. But then, for me, the law has passed for a day only. And there are still many unknown variation. So deep down in my mind, I still wish to go out to protests to-- perhaps a chance to change something. But to be honest, I don't really have any idea if I could actually still go out in the future.
你有多害怕？
How scared are you?
是的，我觉得我现在非常害怕。因为他们说对于重要案件，他们实际上可以跳过香港的法院。我们可以被直接送到内地进行司法审判。
Yeah, I feel like I am very scared right now. Because they are saying that for important case, they could actually skip Hong Kong's court. We could be directly sent to the mainland for their judiciary.
对。法律还有其他部分让你担心吗？
Right. Are there other parts of the law that worry you a lot?
哦，有一条。有一条说香港的老兵，即使我在其他国家，如果我说过任何可能分裂……我不知道这是否被称为分裂国家。比如，说些反政府或反共的话，我可能仍然是非法的。
Oh, there is one. There is one that say Hong Kong veterans, even I am in other country, if I have said anything that could possibly divide-- I don't know if it is called dividing the country. Like, saying something anti-government or anti-communist, I could still be illegal.
对。
Yeah.
这对我来说是非常抽象的事情。我真的不知道它如何被定义，界限在哪里。我不知道即使在没注意的情况下我是否会越界。所以这也是我真正害怕的事情。
There is something very abstract to me. I don't really know how it is being defined and where is the line. And I don't know if I will cross the line, even without being noticing. So that is something really I am afraid of as well.
你觉得民主运动会很快结束吗？
Do you feel like the pro-democracy movement will come to an end very soon?
我想会吧。我想会吧。这就像历史的重演，比如6月4日。
I think it will be. I think it will be. It is like a repeat of history, like the 4th of June.
对，6月4日是天安门广场。
Yeah, 4th of June is Tiananmen Square.
对。人们非常努力地战斗。然后我们有中国政府使用军事力量镇压人们。然后很多年，30年，这么多年后，你看到有这么多人支持政府，已经支持中国政府了。我认为这段历史也会在香港重演。
Yeah. People fought very hard. And then we had the Chinese government suppressing people using military force. And then for many years, 30, so many years later, you see there are so many people supporting the government, supporting the Chinese government already. And I think this history will be repeating in Hong Kong as well.
很快在下一代之后，也许我们会变成那些支持政府的人，就像我们现在嘲笑的那样。他们可能会说，哦，支持中国政府。支持共产党。他们让我们的生活变得美好。如果那一天到来，我想离开香港。我希望我能离开香港。
Soon after our next generation, maybe we'll become those people supporting the government, like we are mocking right now. They will probably say, oh, support Chinese government. Support communists. They made our life good. I want to leave Hong Kong if that day comes. I wish I could leave Hong Kong.
对，你认为有机会吗？
Yeah, do you think there's a chance you could?
我会试着，但我不知道会有多难。我需要看看我是否符合资格。所以这对我来说现在真的是未知的，但我会探索这样做的机会。
I would try to, but I don't know how hard it will be. I need to check if I am eligible. So that is really unknown for me right now, but I will be exploring the chance to do so.
你有许多朋友正在离开或试图离开吗？
Do you have lots of friends who are leaving or trying to leave?
是的，我有。我亲近的同事，他们都计划移民到澳大利亚，一些计划去伦敦。然后我的一些朋友已经决定去加拿大了。我周围确实有很多人离开。
Yeah, I do. My close co-workers, they are all planning migration to Australia, some planning to go to London. And then some of my friends have decided to go to Canada already. Really quite a lot of people around me are leaving.
哇。
Wow.
对，就像每个人都在找路离开这里。
Yeah, like everyone finding a way out of here.
你有什么解脱感吗？因为这已经持续了太久，遥遥无期，但如果这条法律像你说的那样生效，现在你到了一个阶段可以说，好的，我们已经做了所有能做的事。不可能再做任何事情了。我们知道我们不会取得进展。我们必须停止。你从那里面感觉到任何解脱吗？
Do you have any feeling of relief? Like, this has been going on for so long with no end in sight, but if this law kicks in, in the way that you're saying, now you're at a point where you could say, OK, we've done everything we can do. It's impossible to do anything else. We know we're not going to make progress. And we have to stop. Do you feel any relief from that?
不会。不可能是解脱，因为我们正在被镇压，以至于我们不能说话。所以那不可能是解脱。那是一个……那更是一种镇压，就像那种直截了当的镇压。所以不可能是解脱。
No, it won't be. It can't be a relief because we are being suppressed so that we cannot speak. So that cannot be a relief. That is something-- that is more a suppression, like even straight-toward suppression. So that can't be a relief.
我问那个问题是因为伊曼纽尔和香港某人谈过。他们就是这样说的。他们说，好的，好吧，如果这是它要结束的方式，好吧，至少结束了是一种解脱，你知道吗？
I'm asking that question because Emanuele talked to somebody in Hong Kong. And that's what they said. They said, OK, well, if this is how it's going to end, well, at least it's a relief that it's over, you know?
是的，我确实认为有人会这样想。但有一种……我们称之为温水煮青蛙。我不知道这在英语里怎么描述。但是……
Yeah, I do think that there are people thinking in this way. But there is kind of-- we call it cooking a frog in the pot with warm water. I don't know how this-- that being described in English. But then--
不，不，不，我们用英语也有同样的事情，是的，水变得越来越热。
No, no, no, we have that same thing in English, yeah, where the water gets warmer and warmer.
真的？
Really?
是的，然后青蛙……
Yeah, and then the frog--
哦。
Oh.
……从来没意识到，就像，哦，我应该跳出锅子。我也读过，也许那甚至不是真的。也许青蛙确实跳出了锅子。哦，但确实，是的。
--never really realizes, like, oh, I should get out of the pot. And then I've also read, maybe that's not even true. Maybe frogs do jump out of the pot. Oh, but yeah.
但我确实认为有些人会这样想。他们会想，至少我们尝试过，类似那样。但对我自己而言，那不可能是解脱。如果运动结束，那是我们希望下一代记住的事情。这确实在香港发生过。所以那不可能是解脱。我永远不会感到解脱。
But then I do think that some people would think in this way. They would think, at least we've tried, something like that. But for me, myself, that can't be a relief. If the movement ends, that is something that we want our next generation to remember. This has actually happened in Hong Kong. So that can be a relief. I will never feel relieved.
在秋天，我们谈到感觉就像有一个时钟，有一种关于香港失去自治的50年倒计时。你认为通过抗议，你让这种改变发生得比原计划更快了吗？
In the fall, we talked about how it felt like there's this clock and this sort of 50-year countdown to Hong Kong losing its autonomy. Do you think by protesting, you've made this change happen faster than it would have happened?
嗯，老实说，我想也许大多数人想的和我想的一样，就是我们的反抗会因为国际视野、国际舆论、国际支持而让中国政府什么都不做。我们以为运动会减慢倒计时。我们谁也没想到它会加速它。
Mm, to be honest, I think maybe the majority was thinking the way that I am thinking, is that our rebellion would make the Chinese government not do anything because of the international views, international opinion, international support. We thought that the movement would slow down the countdown. None of us have expected that it will fasten it up.
你们开始运动是为了减慢倒计时，而你们没想过它会加速它。对。
You started the movement to slow the countdown, and you didn't think it would make it go faster. Yeah.
对。它本应该在50年发生，比如第50年。但也许随着中国政府的雄心，它将在第40年发生。但现在，甚至更早了。所以这完全出乎意料。
Yeah. It was supposed to happen on the 50 years, like the 50th year. But then maybe with the Chinese government ambition, it was going to happen in the 40th year. But then now, it's even earlier. So that is totally out of expectation.
而且糟得多。
And much worse.
对。
Yeah.
你后悔抗议吗，看到这一点？
Do you regret protesting, seeing that?
不，真的。我不后悔做这件事。因为我们都知道我们只是在为那一点点机会而战。即使我们失败了，至少我们尝试过。所以这真的很悲伤。我们没能得到我们想要的。情况甚至比我们开始整个运动时更糟。
No, really. I am not regret for doing it. Because we all knew that we were only fighting for that tiny chance. And even if we failed, at least we tried. So it is really so sad. We could not get what we wanted. The situation is even worse than the time that we started the whole movement.
但我们所做的一切现在……我不能说它是浪费，因为这一年改变了很多人，好的方面或是坏的方面。所以我不说它是浪费。香港的政治范围完全改变了，人们如何看待彼此，然后社会改变了很多。所以它仍然值得。
But then everything we've been doing is now-- I cannot say it is wasted because this one year have changed many people, like in a good way or in a bad way. So I won't say it is wasted. The political scope in Hong Kong is totally changed, how people see each other, and then the society changed a lot. So it's still worth it.
而且我们向世界发表了宣言，我们不希望中国政府到来。那是我们正在发表的声明。尽管我们失败了，尽管我们正在被政府控制，我们仍然不想让其他人觉得我们要它，我们享受它。不，我们不。我们反对它。只是我们失败了。所以世界知道我们不想要它。
And we have made a declaration to the world that we don't want the Chinese government to come. That is the statement that we are making. Even though we failed, even though we are being controlled by the government, we still don't want to let others feel that we want it, we enjoy it. No, we don't. We fought against it. Just that we failed. So the world knows that we don't want it.
那是香港的詹妮弗。我今天用我们和詹妮弗参加的最后一场抗议的录音来结束我们的节目。那是回十月份在足球场，她跟着唱抗议赞歌《愿荣光归香港》。这周，这首歌在学校被禁了。
That's Jennifer in Hong Kong. I'm going to end our program today with a recording of the last protest that any of us attended with Jennifer. This was back in October in a soccer stadium, where she sang along with the protest anthem, "Glory to Hong Kong." This week, the song was banned from schools.
[用中文唱歌]
[SINGING IN CHINESE]
这是运动最受欢迎的口号之一，“光复香港，时代革命”。上周，高喊这个口号被香港政府宣布根据新法律是非法的。
This is one of the movement's most popular slogans, "Liberate Hong Kong, revolution of our times." Last week, chanting this slogan was declared illegal under the new law by the Hong Kong government.
[用中文高喊]
[CHANTING IN CHINESE]
[音乐 - Ember Island，“雨伞”]
[MUSIC - EMBER ISLAND, "UMBRELLA"]
我们的节目今天由伊曼纽尔·贝里和黛安·吴制作。我们在香港的出色现场制作人是Yannie Chan。感谢我们的翻译Flora Chung、Diana Chan和Dominic Yang。
Our program was produced today by Emanuele Berry and Diane Wu. Our brilliant field producer in Hong Kong was Yannie Chan. Thanks to our interpreters, Flora Chung, Diana Chan, and Dominic Yang.
今天制作我们节目的人包括Elna Baker、Susan Burton、Zoe Chace、Dana Chivvis、Sean Cole、Damien Grave、Michelle Harris、Jessica Lussenhop、Miki Meek、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Ben Phelan、Nadia Reiman、Robyn Semien、Lilly Sullivan、Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。
The people who put together our show today includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Grave, Michelle Harris, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
Noor Gill和Aviva DeKornfeld进行额外制作。我们的执行制作人是David Kestenbaum。今天特别感谢Dave Hill为警匪剧《武装反应》的主题曲制作封面。还要特别感谢Laurel Chor、Karen Cheung、Howard Wong、Noble Wong、Yu、Tse Sai Pei、Alanna Thiede、Jiayang Fan和Martin Lee。
Additional production by Noor Gill and Aviva DeKornfeld. Our executive producer is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Dave Hill for the cover of the theme of the cops show, Armed Reaction. And special thanks to Laurel Chor, Karen Cheung, Howard Wong, Noble Wong, Yu, Tse Sai Pei, Alanna Thiede, Jiayang Fan, and Martin Lee.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。美国生活通过PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，他永远不会忘记他第一次坐旋转木马。正如他讲述故事的方式，他骑上一匹马开始转圈。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our problem's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he'll never forget his first time on a carousel. The way he tells the story, he gets on a horse and starts to go around.
那一刻，我突然意识到，哦，我们其实非常接近革命，它可能发生。
At that moment, I suddenly realized, oh, we're actually very close to a revolution that could happen.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，欢迎收听更多《美国生活》的故事。